[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alain fischer le monsieur vaccin du
gouvernement indique que le pass
vaccinale pourraient disparaître plus
tôt que prévu fin mars début avril
oui il ya des raisons d'espérer qu'à cet
horizon de temps la situation se sera
suffisamment améliorée pour que nous
soyons en mesure de lever ses ultimes
mesures allez on va dire
allez-y
barman a
justement au gérald dahan maintenant on
va en parler je ne dis pas ça ne va pas
faire mal comme une espèce de
gynécologues dix ans détendez-vous
quoique j'ai trouvé ça d'une grande
violence d'une grande agressivité
chose qui ressemble à de la misogynie
eric woerth le président de la
commission des finances à l'assemblée
nationale ancien ministre de nicolas
sarkozy rejoint donc le camp d'emmanuel
macron sa charge est violente contre sa
famille politique il a une punchline il
est plus intéressé dit-il lui par la
france de ses enfants qu'à celle de son
enfance réaction quasi immédiate du
patron des républicains
christian jacob fait part de beaucoup de
déception et de regret évoque un
parlementaire en fin de carrière passe
il faut applaudir moi je m'en fiche
de ce point de vue là enfin voilà le
droit de se tromper de cheval c'est son
c'est son problème je sais qu'il est fan
de d'hippodromes famille la mère de
paris a décidé de transformer ce conseil
en tribune électorale pour relancer une
campagne qui ne décolle pas je vous
rappelle pour votre information un an et
demi pour cent ce matin dans un sondage
est là-bas paru ce matin pour l'express
et bfm tv il ya là le symptôme d'un
rejet le spectre d'une humiliation voir
le risque de l'effacement du parti
socialiste vous madame je sais pas si
vous auriez résister aux bashing de ces
derniers de ces derniers jours
donc nous verrons bien nous verrons bien
mais moi je fais une campagne je vais à
des élections donc les sondages ils vont
et viennent il change tous les jours
pour vous ce sont les sondages qui
décident de l'élection la course des
petits chevaux à laquelle vous dites
vous même ne pas vouloir participer
finalement c'est elle qui devrait faire
le résultat qui devrait même remplacé le
vote non d'ailleurs quand le porte
parole du ps se félicite sur twitter dès
6 ans parrainage enregistré par hidalgo
l'ex cadre du ps julien dray lui réponds
ça
t'as fumé de la bonne ce matin bonne
journée la noblesse de la politique
c'est pas les petits ralliements
individuels ce qu'on a vu encore
aujourd'hui avec eric byrne qui a passé
son quinquennat a voté contre les lois
de marange et qui se range derrière
c'est une action citoyenne qu'ils
espèrent devenir massive sur le parking
de ce centre commercial ils sont une
centaine à s'être donné rendez vous dès
gilet jaune des manifestants anti passe
et cinquantaine de véhicules qui
plissent mais combien sont-ils à paris
samedi des groupes facebook ont été
créées pour appeler à la mobilisation
celui ci compte plus de 300 mille
inscrits j'ai vu certains pour
l'intention d'utiliser ces convois pour
en quelque sorte revenir avec des
revendications qui n'ont pas été
satisfaites des gilet jaune est
évidemment que nous les soutenons
toujours pas tout de suite m'accuser de
récupération non c'est pas de la
récupération je viens dire à ceux qui
sont scandalisés par le pass vaccinale
ceux qui sont scandalisés par la hausse
terrible de du carburant que il faut
voter et d'elin la violence elle
n'attend pas grand-chose pour bouger
s'il ya eu un léger les jaunes et j'ai
je ne sais pas fini les gilet jaune ça a
été détruit par les prétendus en cause
anti fasciste c'était détruit aussi par
le pouvoir on sait comment les
maquereaux ni un titre et à la fin le
convoi et la rive pour faire le siège de
total à la défense où je vous assure que
j'y serai très favorable pour un plein
de 50 euros ils auront une remise de 50
litres par dont ils ont une remise de 5
euros donc 10 centimes par litre la
remise de 10 centimes par litre avec
l'acs bien sauf qu'en réalité total
énergie il va se contenter au final de
s'aligner sur ses principaux concurrents